through it all Major's new girlfriend
actress Megan Good has remained by his
side even present for our interview how
would you describe your relationship
she's an angel she's held me down
like like a ketta oh hell no did he
bring up that caretta [__]
again yo this dude is weird this dude is
super did he say ketta
again like like Michelle
Obama yo send this man to jail for
corniness apparently Jonathan major did
some kind of interview I haven't watched
it some people recommend checking it out
so I told you time isn't what you think
less than a year ago the name Jonathan
Majors was followed by talk of critical
and box office success skyrocketing Fame
even Oscar buzz I'm coming for
everything but this morning a different
conversation surrounds that Mary name
something about sitting here right now
and and and looking at you and
understanding the gravity of the
situation
um a situation that I in many ways you
know put myself in the actor spoke
exclusively with ABC news for the first
time after being convicted in late
December for harassment and misdemeanor
reckless in the third degree which could
carry a penalty of up to a year Behind
Bars why did you decide you wanted to
talk now I felt like it was time
um a lot has
happened um in my personal life in my
career um in the culture it's about
responsibility and coming forward and
being brave and and giving my my part of
the story your reaction to that
verdict
shock I was uh I was absolutely shocked
and
um afraid I'm standing there and the
verdict comes down I say how how how is
how is that possible based off the
evidence based off the prosecution's
evidence
let alone our evidence how was that
possible but after only hours of
deliberation a jury of his peers agreed
with prosecutors that he did physically
injure his then girlfriend Grace Jabari
in an incident last March what happened
exactly do you know no I don't know um
what I know that part oh he knock I
thought you talking about the
dispatcher's Jamaican accent W son W
Happ star uh I know she unconscious
unconscious scene the breeding no she
breeding okay okay boy you know what
listen to me what going to do you're
done you're done so you hear police are
come they're going to Cuff you up you're
done what happened exactly do you
know you hear Y what happenly you know
you hear it you heard it right my ear
didn't deceive me okay I'm just glad it
is a car be asking what happened here
you know no I don't know um uh she been
conscious that 911 call from Majors came
hours after an argument broke out with
Jabari in the backseat of an SUV when
Majors received a text from another
woman saying oh how I wish to be kissing
you Jabari testified that when she
grabbed the phone Majors tried to get it
back fracturing her finger and giving
her a cut behind her ear she says inside
the car you hit her in the face twist
her arm behind her back fracture her
middle finger yeah that did not happen
how did those injuries come
about I wish the god I
knew that would give Clarity that would
give me some type of Peace about it but
you're confident you didn't I have no
question surveillance video shows major
getting out of the car followed by
Jabari whom he then puts back inside the
vehicle what happens next is what the
defense remains focused on Majors runs
off and Jabari chases after him if you
watch those videos and you reverse that
and you saw a black man chasing a young
white girl down the street screaming and
crying that man is going to be shot and
killed in the streets of New York City
major defense team shared these photos
which he says show the injuries he
received that night which were deemed
inadmissible in court how were you
injured my injuries were um I scratched
on my hand you know from clawing for the
phone and I had a gash on my at the time
I had a beard under my beard I had
essentially a fing out scratch it's
interesting that he can admit that she
injured him in that tussle but he can't
acknowledge that he would have injured
her in that tussle ain't that
interesting he said it's physical enough
for him to get hurt but he's convinced
that in him trying to grab the phone
that she snatched that there's no way he
could AFF
you saw how easily he lifted her up like
a rag do ched her in and you clearly see
her head banging on the top of the thing
you know when the cops go put their hand
watch your head
bang listen when you grab someone and
they're significantly like way less than
you and you're just raged all him in
Adrenaline pump it you might not even
recognize the fact no look I'm not even
trying to say that he's wrong for doing
this I already said before someone takes
your property you can use Force to get
it back that's not the defense he went
with he went with the defense I didn't
hurt her so you're hearing it now he
went with the defense it didn't happen
yeah he didn't hurt her that's what he's
saying he didn't hurt her that's what he
said right now it's like no you did hurt
her but you did in the process of
getting your phone back which is okay he
just didn't go that defense so me
listening to him now I understand why
the jury went back there and then found
him guilty of it but I also understand
the point that he's making where it's
like you don't see my injuries you don't
see the fact that I ran away from her
but I think that's on him for choosing
the wrong form of Defense yeah if you
want a self-defense claim you have to
claim self-defense he didn't make that
CLA that was just one of the weird
things that happened with this case but
anyways if you guys didn't watch it you
guys going see your full video the
prosecution also played audio Jabari had
recorded earlier in the relationship
where Majors encouraged her to act more
like ketta Scott King and Michelle Obama
I a great man a great man I am doing
great things not just for me but for my
for my culture and for the world that is
actually the position I'm in the woman
that supports me needs to be a great
woman there are some who question
especially in the black community as
you're probably well aware that that
people were saying why was he telling
this woman to be like gr Scott King and
and Michelle Obama it was me trying to
give an analogy of of what it is I'm
aspiring to be you know these Great
Men
Martin President Obama um and trying to
give a reference point to that one of
the things I also say is like I need her
and I IE Grace to make this same
sacrifices that I am making yeah I'm not
going to lie that statement didn't come
out good it looked terrible you know
what also looked terrible uh the text
messages between the two of them are the
emails that his lawyer released okay I'm
going to read these texts go ahead I
fear this this is what he's saying to
her I fear you have no perspective of
what could happen if you go to the
hospital Majors wrote they will ask you
questions as I don't think you actually
and I don't think you actually protect
us it could lead to an investigation
even if if you do lie and they suspect
something then Jabari the girl responds
I will tell the doctor I bumped my head
if I go I'm going to give it one more
day but I can't sleep and need some
stronger painkillers that's all why
would I want to tell them what really
happened when it's clear I want to be
with
you hey you released this [__] n you
thought this Vindicated you hey yo my
man it made him look guilty and it was
his own lawyers who released it and I'm
like bro I actually thought he was
innocent at first then I saw those
emails and I
went how did you hire lawyers who who
who released those emails that blew my
mind when I saw that [__] come out
publicly so all in all I stand by what I
said and now hearing him now I stand by
it even more he hired the wrong defense
or he didn't listen to their counsel and
did whatever the [__] he wanted either
way this is incompetence not a
miscarriage of Justice that's so crazy
after this [__] broke apparently a bunch
of people who' known him for years said
this dude has a history of doing weird
[__] to people people since like his
university days so a bunch of people who
knew from back then just flooded Twitter
and be like oh this piece of [__] it
seems all the stuff online is mostly
about the physical stuff and actual
harassment claims They Don't Really
detail it okay in a statement to ABC
News an attorney for Jabari said in part
it is not at all surprising that Mr
major continues to take no
accountability for his actions adding
the timing of these new statements
demonstrates a clear lack of remorse for
his actions do you feel you're not
responsible for her injuries at all I
shouldn't have been in the car that's
not what she ass [__] sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I shouldn't have stepped out of the
relationship I shouldn't have been in
the relationship if I'm not in the
car none of this is happening if I leave
the relationship none of this is
happening if I'm man enough or brave
enough to say I want to see somebody
else or I'm I'm done now I'm not in that
car we're not here I'm responsible for
those things do you feel you're not
responsible for her injuries at all I
shouldn't have been in the car that's
not what she is
[__] can I
react thank you and you guys want to
know why this guy's guilty because of
this stuff because of this answer yeah
what is my man doing this does not sound
like an innocent person whatsoever my
God if I didn't hit you and I know I
didn't hit you I'm repeating it a
thousand times I never hit you I never
touched her and I'd be getting [__]
angry about it cuz I know I didn't do
that [__] through it all Major's new
girlfriend actress Megan Good has
remained by his side even present for
our interview how would you describe
your relationship she's an angel she's
held me down
like Michael ketta oh hell no did he
bring up that ketta [__]
again yo this dude is weird this dude is
super did he say ketta
again like like M
Obama yo send this man to jail for
corniness but I
think what you okay so let's roll back
on something that you said you said that
yo this girl coming back so quick in the
relationship right after is weird yeah
it is H you're right it is weird she
kept a seat for me at the front like my
Rosa Parks shut the
[__] you know what you need to stop
mentioning our civil rights leaders you
know what you you want to have you don't
want to have a rose apart by your side
you don't want to find your ketta huh
you don't want to get your Rita Marley
yeah you don't want
to no you don't want none of that listen
you don't want to find your Queen Sheba
however you feel about this case y'all
can't deny this dude is extremely weird
you
know I'm so blessed to have her you know
the relationship
is still fresh but you
know I think I found her the March 2023
incident thrust major dating history
into the Forefront a rolling stone
article back in June detailed multiple
allegations of abusive Behavior dating
back to Majors relationships in college
allegations Majors vehemently denies his
attorneys offered past partners to
defend him have you ever had issues with
domestic
abuse i' I've witnessed it um but never
participated you know oh my God God this
dude stopped doing interview stop
talking about these topics stay away
from cameras every time you talk you
just look guilty I didn't think anything
about this past stuff now that you're
talking about it you just sound off
something about this guy is just off am
I
crazy uh I I never participated but I
did witness it um uh what kind of
response is that don't you think there's
some hints of Juicy smolier in there you
know what I
mean and and that like there's a bit
of it's just an act it's not
act I don't know hey man listen stay
away from cameras you're not good if if
it's not if you're not acting if you're
not paid don't don't don't try to act as
a real person because you're not good at
it just be an actor and stay away from
Real Life Energy Jesus Christ that's cuz
you are not good at being a real person
that's rough you not get no Oscars
anything else you want to say good Lord
that was brutal was it not bad I I was
ready to have my mind sede and is it's
the cretive stuff that's a bit rough
it's the cor why are you so obsessed no
but it's also as answers to everything
else did you harm her I shouldn't have
been in the car you know how we you know
how did you did you harm anybody in did
you harm anybody in college uh I
witnessed what did you witness you know
what it sounds like what a
politician it's a PR team of a
politician that's what that
[__]